At.
Ang mga quantum computer ay napaka-sensitibo sa ingay—
mga abala na nagdudulot ng mga error
sa kanilang mga kalkulasyon, pero ipinapakita ng bagong pananaliksik
na ang mga noisy na quantum computer ng IBM ay katumbas ng eksaktong mga klasikal na pamamaraan
at nagpapatunay ng mga rehiyon na mas mahusay kaysa sa mga sopistikadong klasikal na
pamamaraan ng approximation sa parehong nabeberipika
at mga hindi nabeberipikang rehiyon
para sa isang mapaghamong eksperimento sa simulation.
Paano nila nagawa ito? Gumamit sila ng espesyal na teknik
para harapin ang ingay
sa mga quantum system — tinatawag itong error mitigation.
Sa pamamagitan ng teknik na error mitigation
na ginamit sa eksperimentong ito, pinatakbo namin ang aming mga kalkulasyon
habang dahan-dahang dinadagdagan ang ingay.
Pagkatapos, binalikan namin ang resulta papunta sa zero na ingay.
Ang gawaing ito ay nagdadala sa atin ng isang hakbang na mas malapit sa kapaki-pakinabang na quantum computing
tayo